you're always being the funny guy in the
movie and in this movie bloodline huge
departure you're playing a serial killer
yeah it was the most comfortable I've
ever been played like yeah you know it's
like people asked did you know did you
go home and you know what was it really
heavy like you know and I was it first
of all I'm not Daniel day-lewis
nobody has ever confused me with Daniel
day-lewis and I'm certainly not gonna go
home and channel the role of serial
killer you shoot this thing for a month
I'm not gonna think about all the people
I want to kill yeah I'd go home watch
some football drink some beer and write
so you enjoyed it you enjoyed playing a
serial killer it felt right to you
really right yeah you know I don't I
can't really describe it but I just felt
like I've been waiting to do this yeah a
long time yeah yeah yeah but role not
kill and kill again
exactly yeah it was funny because we I
watched the movie with my mom and your
mom is like at the premiere it was at
home what had a link to the movie I saw
you wanna show it to her yes so I was
like was really excited to show her I
knew that you know it was like I finally
get a chance to do something different
and and and I would like I'd look over
at her to see how she was responding and
she she looked at me like I catch you
two looking at me like she was
uncomfortable like she was confused if
then I was like it's a little weird yeah
and then after the movies what you think
what you think she's like you know did a
great job it was really believable yeah
it's like okay and the way she was
looking at me was like remember in The
Omen when like the mom this like finds
out that it's not that Damien is this
spawn of the devil that's what she is
that's how she was looking at and she
hasn't really talked to me since yeah
yeah no she's actually gone into witness
protection
yeah speaking of your family I know you
have a bunch of siblings like brothers
do they do they support you when you do
a movie are they supportive because
siblings get be funny that way yeah I
mean well I have one brother where we
were at a premiere and it was a bad
movie it was it was I was in a stinker I
was a real piece of [ __ ] okay and and
and you could tell yeah at the premiere
it was quiet like you know and then in
that there's the premiere party
afterwards and you know when you're in a
real bomb when like everybody's looking
at each other and they don't really know
what to say
and then people you know like they would
come up to me and like so the movie it
looked like you had a lot of fun making
it you look like you look like you had a
whole lot of fun is code it's clip like
you had a lot of exactly and then the
next one is like so what do you know
coming up next yeah you know but my
brother at that movie he looked at me as
like what did you make that movie man
he's like your brother said yeah he's
like I took time off of work for this
movies have you made a school
so yeah call the check yeah